اعطيني فاطمه نادره في زمن العباءه
والعمام الطويل هل انقسم النظام
قالبه فاول المنشقين وهو القائد السابق في
الحرس الثوري هي احد داخليه بين بقايا عهد
روحاني ورجال عهد رئيسي الحرس الثوري
بالاحرى بموجبها تم تسريحه خمسه الاف
موظفا من عهد الحكومه السابقه منذ بدء
الانتفاضه اجراءات والاحترازيه خشيه
القلاب على حكومه رئيس هيئه رئيس البرلمان
فشلت في تحسين الاوضاع المعيشيه
للايرانيين في ظل تراجع القدره الشرائيه
وانهيار العملاء
الى عبد الناصر هم في رئيس البنك المركزي
في حكومه روحاني دعا رئيسي وحكوماته الى
الاستقاله بعده تنصلها من مسؤوليه الفشل
الاقتصادي وتحميلها للحكومه السابقه وخداع
الشعب اتهام مباشر
وسندته في الساعه 60 بالارقام الرسميه
المممقه كي لا نقول الكذبه التضخم الذي
تتلقف الحكومه المتعاقبتان مسؤوليه في
جاره يبلغ اليوم
84% في حين كان يبلغ 34 في المئه عام 2020
اي في عهد روحاني وعندما تولى رئيس مصر
رئيس ايران كانت الدولار الامريكي يساوي
230,000 ريال في اسواق الطيران والان قيمه
كل دولار امريكي تزيد عن
380.000 ريال ومع ذلك يبقى نصف الحقيقه
الاخر الذي التي تحدثنا عنها غائبا من
يهند السياسات البلاد ومن يقوى على عكس
واقعي حياه الايرانيين على جميع الاصعده
لا احد يحكم هنا
سوى المرشد وحين نتحدث عن الاقتصاد وهو
الكعكه المقسمه بين خامنئي والحرس الثوري
وبدايه تقسيمها كانت في عام 2016 بمرسوم
خامنئي لخصخصه 80% من القطاع العام
فتحت بموجبه بوابه الحرس الثوري من العسكر
والسياسه الى الاقتصاد بتصفيه شركات
الدوله انضم اقل من 14% منها فقط للقطاع
الخاص وما تبقى من اصول
86% قيمتها 70 مليار دولار ذهبت الى
القطاع شبه الحكومي الذي استحدث حينها
للحرس الثوري ومؤسساته ومؤسسات المرشد ومن
بينها تلك التي تستثر مظله الاعمال
الخيريه بحجم 200 مليار دولار هذا بتوثيق
امريكي
تحت عيني و ضوء المرشد الاخضر تاسست خاتم
الانبياء الشركات التي تتجاوز قيمتها
المئه مليار دولار غطاء مقاولات هندسيه
يضم
815 شركه في البلاد والخارجها مهمتها كانت
تدمير القطاع الخاص بمد الحرس يده الى
قطاعات اخرى كالتصالات طبعا لاغراض امنيه
وتلبيها حصه 51% من شركه الاتصالات
الايرانيه استحفظ عليها الحرس الثوري في
2009 مقابل سبعه مليارات و800 مليون دولار
وهناك ايضا البتروكيماويات الصناعات
الثقيله قطاعات السيارات الصحه والسرعه في
حلولي 2009 ايضا كانت المصارف الخاصه تملك
فقط 34% من الودائع طويله الامد في البلاد
وخمسه وعشرين في المئه فقط من الودائع
قصيره الامد
يا ذهبت الى 12 مصرفا ومؤسسا ماليه مرتبطه
في الحرس الثوري ومن خلالها يتحكم باسعار
الفائده ويشغل حسابات المصرفيه وهميه بلغ
عددها في 2015 بحسب البنك المركزي
الايراني
بريئاستهمته 38 مليون حساب استخدمت في
صفقات مشهوره
مبالغ طائله في مختلف القطاعات حددت من
حصول رجال الاعمال على قرودا لتطوير
اعمالهم مقابل الرفاهيه المطلقه لشركات
الحرس وقياداتهم المتكئين على وساده من
ريش عام النفط والغاز مهمه
لمقر خاتم الانبياء بحصص ثابته
كل المقايضه احيانا
[موسيقى]